what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch the
movie Friday first time watching for
both myself and of course salamander the
Sally La Monaco
Sally how are you my dear I'm great
good this is good rapport right here
solid solid opening back and forth we
have accomplished our goals today you've
never even really heard of this movie
before right no I had to Google it when
you told me at first I thought you meant
Friday the 13th I was like did you
forget to write the rest
so I'm excited yeah I've never seen it a
mid 90s comedy uh it's been recommended
a bunch it's a hard R and uh YouTube has
been uh you know really they've been
delicate lately very very sensitive
folks so uh if things have to be you
know a little bit censored please
understand why we have to do it leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated uh
subscribe and click that Bell for any
other movie reactions we got up here on
the channel so I was recovering movies
again with us as of late because she
lives in the NYC follow Sally on her own
uh YouTube channel as well
I've been putting the wrong Link in the
description box apparently all this time
and lastly full interaction watch along
as we sing it with your own copy of
Friday available for super sexy Rejects
at our patreon page along with a bunch
of other things that we covered
exclusively over there all right Sally
you ready you ready to do this ready
ready so excited ready for me to hit
play on Netflix all right let's do it
let's do it okay
[Music]
I know you don't smoke weed I know this
but I'm gonna get you high today
cause it's Friday
you ain't got no job and you ain't got
[ __ ] to do
he's talking to me
Fridays
I love that
our Fridays when you lived out here in
California oh my God they were
I love that we're covering this
that looks like our neighborhood
I wonder if this is right when Ice Cube
started getting into acting I don't
really know the history of Ice Cube too
well I don't either because this came
out when I was born so oh gotcha
it's
great
oh I love them both
Wayne's brother's show
give me the 2p special lots of hot sauce
and all the fries you can give me
foreign
[Laughter]
a great thing to dream about I know
he'll be so disappointed when he wakes
up
good morning are you prepared for
Jehovah's return because if you're not I
have a panther
[Laughter]
well you
laughs
ain't nothing in this house
every time I come in the kitchen you in
the kitchen
didn't I tell you to take out the
picture fell asleep I wish you were
sleeping right now I'll knock you upside
your head with a left foot make your ass
break up and take out that damn trash
what are you doing I'm throwing this
away we ain't even got no milk you
better put some water on that damn [ __ ]
it
all right there's some water on that
damn [ __ ]
I don't know in the back room
oh no oh man I'll wait till you come Out
Boy bring your ass off up in here would
you tell me you wait till I come on I
smelled your [ __ ] with 22 years now you
can't smell my mouth
now your mama told me what happened to
you yesterday how the hell you gonna get
fired on your day off
I don't know you need to trade
take a look at that paper over there
got to counter there
oh my God
I ain't trying to be no dog catcher why
not I don't even like dogs that's the
beauty of it I grab a dog
and I took him you're not I kicked the
[ __ ] out of him and
I believe on my foot up a dog's ass
[ __ ]
who would marry this guy he'd be
surprised I didn't go to the show last
night
it's a lie ain't nobody lying I didn't
go to the show
went to the show
I don't know why are you messing with
that little fast ass girl anyway
now that other girl Debbie
she's in school she has all her teeth
she has all her teeth
you know what your problem is
you have no game
what you know about gang
I know your father He Got Game
don't nobody go in the bathroom for
about 35 45 minutes
you better watch when do you climbing
that food before you get blasted on with
what yeah you ain't the man with this oh
my God you still ain't so that weed
smoke cause I broke these days I don't
think you applying yourself Smokey huh
you smoking my [ __ ] hell no
why would I do some [ __ ] like that I'm
gonna have to [ __ ] you up smoking
playing with my money is like playing
with my emotions
I went in there pick up my check came
home supervisor called me about four
o'clock talking about they got me on
video tape stealing boxes
you doing stealing boxes for
you trying to build a clubhouse
[Laughter]
oh God damn man look
oh wow
who is she
what you doing up so early you know that
Diva don't have this bike for like three
weeks right right I won give me my money
you what hello
I lost
you want me to ask for my bike back you
know I wouldn't trip that bike
it's right here
[Music]
it's just like it's both ours
it's like it's both parts
oh yeah
[Music]
you got knocked up
[Laughter]
interestingly edited movie
excuse me what could y'all stay out for
grass please
Smokey I need you to go to the store and
give me some cigarettes give me the
money
make it enough
foreign
oh my God
damn I knocked the dust off Deadpool
wow a lot
of parking in there right man oh she
know what she doing with them little ass
shorts on but you know we be looking
make sure if you leave you lock up the
house and answer the phone the cable
people are supposed to go all right
look at her now she's gonna be ashamed
of herself coming out looking like that
hey girl
all right I'm on my way to work call me
when you get home
okay
[Laughter]
man ain't nothing wrong with smoking
weed weed is from the Earth
God put this here for me and you
take advantage man take advantage
[Laughter]
that is a lot oh that's my song
this is Michael Jackson dancing
what
probably smoke bud too how you doing
brother Craig how you doing I'm all
right
we call it sentencing in sin we're
around here but team Normandy and Weston
we call this here a little twinning twin
twins
a little bit from my cataract you didn't
put in on this man you better get a
receipt my brother look look look she
bending over clawed hammers so
thank you
ohm said you'll take it easy yes sir
oh no
it's Angel though
slide it real hard right
[Laughter]
next thing I know I was running down the
street in my damn drop
oh my god
get on me I'm in Debo pigeon coop
sweating like a slave
and the only person could get me out
with my mom
[Music]
don't let me get you boys
[Laughter]
y'all can't see me huh it's actually a
really well done shot yeah it was
[Music]
oh what
oh [ __ ]
that's all he do damn
[Music]
it's calling it I love this genre shot
so much yeah
what you got on my drink
no
it's just straight up that's people
Jesus
dang that was wonderful man come on
smokers go in if somebody comes
Wilson and I ain't trying to get
involved with y'all you don't get
involved I'm Gonna Knock your ass out
too
make a choice
[Laughter]
foreign
Mr Parker
oh man come on
foreign
[Music]
yeah ain't like you got [ __ ] to do
tomorrow you don't have to go to work
won't take it I got a drink okay
you stimulate your mind
you ain't got [ __ ] to do oh my God peer
pressure is a hell of a thing
just reminds me of the good old days
what's gonna happen not gonna get a job
like a pro I gonna be supplying you
you're gonna be talking about my [ __ ]
oh this is where it came from
goodbye Felicia
what's up Craig
what's up smokey nothing
what y'all smoking
let me borrow a joint you need to borrow
a job with your broke ass always trying
to smoke up somebody's [ __ ] pray
bye Felicia
[Laughter]
the birds kicking in
I'll start tripping Creek
Chris Tucker is always bad
hold up
I gave my heartbeat man that's what it's
supposed to do
you're funny looking
I don't do that gay [ __ ] now
this is just like a hangout movie yeah
yeah it's smokey
he's home what
and she said you wanted to hook up
what's up
are you high
huh are you high oh where'd you say that
because you look like you've been
smoking
yeah I still look I still look out
still looks hot
again for real
Janet Jackson this is before like Tinder
smartphones so he doesn't describe what
you look like
she is a trip I know that's her sister
one time he grabbed me no yes grabbed me
like this
for it I mean was it like this or was it
like this
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey uh I got to go in here in the back
room real quick
that's such a hyping music
you know my homie want to hook up with
you oh crap
[Music]
what happened to you
got bit in the ass today son my stinking
ass filthy dog you should have seen it
biggest dog I've ever seen in my life
and I turned around to jump over the
fence the dog grab my ass oh my God
how your ass feel Mr get out of my house
and don't slam that door all right man
laughs
what you gonna do
is it the drug dealer yeah it's the drug
dealer
I'm gonna be here 10 o'clock on the dot
not 1003 not 10 36. if you ain't got my
money or my bud I'm killing you and him
can I have my chili Fritos I can't have
[ __ ] I'm close fat boy uh
mama
mama
hey
we need to pay him hey crazy man let's
stick together I can't believe you got
me in the mix with this fool
oh man put that joint to your lip and
make you smoke it might as well it's
Friday I'm gonna get you high
why you bringing up old [ __ ]
can I go inside and get it hey come on
I would love to sit on this front porch
right right
oh [ __ ] look where I guess oh oh no
oh yeah now oh you did
that's messed up
[Laughter]
that's just different from down the
street
she was just just go in the house
look at that get your ass in the house
all right man I'm gonna go to crib man
my stomach hurt come back
hi
well it just becomes like a hard-hitting
street drama
number one number two
you ain't gonna drop no thinking loads
here
anybody drop this thing alone it's gonna
be me let's stop
oh man
I'm we're the uh warped by this movie
it's like
I'm
strangely entranced by this experience
I've lived in and I'm just like yeah
this is
such a weird hangout movie
you man when you're done I clean all
that [ __ ] up for you for two dollars
two dollars you got some money
about two hundred dollars you gonna give
me
[Laughter]
you're slick don't come over here ask me
for some money
[Music]
it's like comforting but the sad it is
like
[Music]
[Laughter]
see
I'ma tell them you ain't got nothing to
do with it
I smoked up his weed
imma face the consequence
if I get dealt with I get dealt with
Friday
the Oscar moment yeah what's that for
protection this one makes you a man you
win some you lose some
but you live
you live to fight another day
wow this is
[Laughter]
we kept rewinding it kind of looked like
you're here but you can't really tell
from the back
are you at oh it's cool
[Music]
[Laughter]
I've been wondering when I explore this
is so good
um
[Laughter]
why are you tripping Depot mess don't
you give him back his chain what chain
yeah what changed
put your fists up man
fight him lose
and I got mind control over Debo
he'd be like shut the [ __ ] up
I be quiet
but when he leaves
I'll be talking again
remember grandma would give me that
chain
this is a roller coaster
oh
my God
[Music]
[Music]
okay
this neighborhood has to come together
to save smokey
hey what's up with me
I was in there on the phone with Debbie
and uh what's up Arena we know who Rita
is going to be here at 7 30.
that's my friend I'm
triggered that's Janet Jackson
Janet Jackson The Girl Debbie hooked me
up with he about to get catfished before
catfishing was a thing
[Music]
oh
not a damn thing
we can kick it but I forgot I had to go
pick up my mom from work that's all
right I'll take you to get it ah she
don't like a lot of people with me when
I go get it
oh my God
look won't you go up the street and get
something to eat I know you hungry
[Music]
yeah ate twice before I came God damn
[Laughter]
why you woke me up with that fat ass
bald head girl oh Rita yeah
Rita is not fat she's just big bones
[ __ ]
ah
talking about she look like Janet
Jackson oh no she didn't go there yeah
[ __ ] got out of the car looking more
like Freddie Jackson don't laugh it
ain't funny she was in Fresh Prince
oh okay yeah I was trying to figure it
out too Felicia [ __ ] demo too could
you mind your own business or your mama
is my mama is in Vegas with her
boyfriend so y'all just Pauline up in
here huh oh [ __ ] party over here
[Laughter]
fully shun him huh
[Laughter]
oh disgusting oh it's so gross
foreign
just leave it there what are you doing
what what
I'm getting in the water oh yeah oh my
God this guy
[Music]
hey what the hell are you doing in here
hey be quiet it's got so suspenseful so
fast just when I was gonna get the money
little crackhead these they'll come
running through the window woke him up
he's trying to beat his ass
get that man let's just go back over he
probably still sleep for real yeah
you're breaking in though you gonna be
with me I got you man
[Music]
true friendship this movie is about true
friends yeah exactly
have him beat up
the drug dealer guy
huh
what's this can't catch me
all right guys
too
make his ass
[Music]
hey um
somebody uh
hey smokey
don't play dumb you know
[Laughter]
I think we better stay in the house
why don't you sell the gun yeah I
literally saw anything
just smoking them Tweeds and everything
wearing the old clothes all half off
your ass what the hell's going on today
huh weeds
man ain't nobody even out here
I don't even know why I'm tripping if I
want to mess with the Smoke Dog
[ __ ] damn
for two hundred dollars
yeah but if you adjust for inflation
it's like four hundred dollars that's
awful hurry up hurry up hurry up
dude this guy's gonna get two hundred
dollars
one two three
you see him yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
look at your face
are you okay no look at your face
what you hit my sister like she was a
man
some business going through my pants
while I was sleep my sister don't need
to steal nothing from your broke ass all
right
you lucky I'm not a man otherwise I kick
your ass myself
oh hell no uh-uh man that's a female
shut your little punk ass up looking for
a drop you like I did this [ __ ] and I
ain't even trying to fight you Debo
bro no no you wanna fight me because
you're gonna build up
[Applause]
[Music]
it's gonna do with that your dad's gonna
be disappointed
yeah
put that gun down some
I get knocked out like your father used
to
whoa what what
Craig
give me give me a guy knock him out
punch him
foreign
oh you can beat him and take the 200.
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that hurt my back looking at it come on
Craig told y'all JoJo
prank come on Craig come on Craig
fair enough
come on man
oh
holy [ __ ]
yes Mr big shot
let's go
no guns but bricks are okay yeah bricks
are okay yes
that's what I'm talking about that's my
dog still a 200 we're good like
all right Mom
you got knocked them
[Laughter]
nice Grandmama gave me this chain
nice
Felicia get in there
[Music]
because I steal I don't kill
me oh I got his bike back I was just
wondering that maybe if you're feeling
better than
that
feeling better already
a long Friday
laughs
they've been awake for like 14 hours I
think
that's right
did he just break the fourth wall yeah
he's done it a couple times why you
you know why I waste my time on your old
stupid ass anyway I don't know either
it's over [ __ ]
I got your money anyway
and you share that [ __ ] yourself next
time
cause I'm going to rehab
I'm through with this [ __ ]
character development we love it
I was just bullshitting and you know
this man
Friday
we should have watched it on Friday it's
Saturday I know
like goddamn morons
we're such idiots
I I don't think there's a post-credit
scene salary
I adventure to guess that it doesn't set
up the cinema of Friday too well there
is two more Fridays after this actually
I think there's there's not a Multiverse
I think there's next Friday and then
yeah really that's what it's called next
Friday and then Friday after yeah I
think it's yeah I think you're right
yeah Friday After Next is so goes next
Friday then Friday After Next
oh my God
I don't think Chris Tucker returns for
the other ones why he was this he was
the moment you know what I mean he was
the moment I I know what you went to
rehab that's why oh yeah or they killed
him off or something I don't know what
happened I'd be curious to find out
though damn this must be like massive
ass hits
anyway not me realizing I dated someone
like Smoky not too long ago I was like
huh did you really
listen
desperate times
either grow your ass up man
anyway
let's talk about it okay I thought that
was
um it was so it was different than what
I expected it to be it took me a little
we were like Sally it's gonna be dark
it's gonna be darker than I thought it'd
be like more than to rush hour I thought
it'd be more edgy and [ __ ] like rush
hour is more of like a Hollywood script
Punchy comedy film yeah and and this
felt like a an interesting like you know
crude rude sassy
satire very a few locations you know
yeah it's like a hangout movie yeah and
I thought that was really cool that they
just like made a a really solid hangout
movie with these guys and it took like
it took me a little bit of time to like
adjust to it because I was under the
impression might just be like some some
wacky comedy pretty much
um but yeah it's got this I'm like Dude
Where's My Car yeah I was expecting Dude
Where's My Car yeah like a sketch comedy
yeah um but yeah it's got like a
interesting direction and you know I
like the I like the crass humor uh that
it has
and so yeah I mean it was
it was it was interesting because it
seemed to carry this like sometimes I
decided to get like a little serious
insertion scenes obviously
and it yeah it would uh which like threw
me off a little bit because I was like
where's the joke and then it didn't come
and I was like oh wow they go in there I
thought the ending would have more of a
serious part two you know what I mean
yeah but yeah I thought there'd be a
little bit more of a perhaps a serious
but you got the girls though he got the
girl he actually wanted and I I feel
like the
how do I put it I I think there's a bit
of like an interesting poignancy in this
film where it seems like there are some
like real world like it's six this came
out when did it come out let me look it
up really fast 1995 95 that's right the
year you were born yeah I came out uh it
came out in 1995 and it was it was it
was sort of like having that resonating
um like real world things that a lot of
African-American neighborhoods had to
deal with still do and so so dealing
with that throughout but also finding
like a sense of community by the end of
it all which I was like there's
something I kept saying I was like
there's something comforting about it I
don't know whatever yeah I I didn't I
can't quite put my finger on it either
because about like 15-20 minutes when
I'm like I'm not really like cracking up
but I'm definitely like
and interesting I'm definitely
interested in enjoying it and I'm and
I'm watching and I'm really just like
I I don't I couldn't I couldn't find the
words it took me a while but there's
something that feels like while wacky
but also
weirdly authentic you know in a strange
way definitely I feel I feel like
writing from experience but then being
able
to add comedy
comment the mood from their experiences
probably living in neighborhoods like
this yeah
that's how I felt it was I mean not to I
feel dumb like a white person wearing a
[ __ ] stop gun violence
well it's not huge guns
um but like I lived in a really low
income area and I lived in neighborhoods
like this in Florida
and it kind of weirdly reminded me as a
kid of like growing up with people like
this and it was kind of we had a blast
all the time and there was always weird
neighborhood drama we'd all as kids we'd
be on our bikes like getting into it and
like doing stupid [ __ ] and
um but I can't imagine like actually
having that much violence and trying to
like just having it be an everyday thing
because we'd see stuff but as kids but
we were never like involved in it
um so I just it made me kind of
feel a little sad that this is
definitely their reality a lot at least
that's what I'm assuming from the
writing like it it just the writing
sounded very authentic and just like I
don't know I thought it was if in that
sense I'm just like I think it was
well done for uh us a smaller scale
movie and for something that they're
probably you know drawing from
experience on I guess but making it
funny and yeah they also they managed to
have it with the the backdrop that
weirdly has a
a line of tragedy and comedy but they
also have it as a stoner comedy and you
know like ice cubing and Chris Tucker
they do have like they do have surprise
like there's such different you know
your economy tend to have a high energy
low energy character or more of the
straight man and the high energy wacky
one and which there's always that duo
with friends there's like the the one
that's like high all the time and like
you know got a lot going on and there's
like the chill like level-headed one and
it's like it's so accurate yeah
friendships and I think they have they
have good but they both bring a good
energy to the screen and I also think
that uh yeah I mean in a lot of ways
it's more of Chris Tucker's show in here
and he's really I'm sorry he's not in
the other ones really I don't think so
that's what I've been trying to find out
while we've been talking because I've
been looking I've been looking into it
it was like a good buddy comedy like I'm
I feel like they had really good
chemistry it's hard to imagine the next
one without him not even having him in
it yeah
yeah just his facial expressions alone
I'm gonna be like he's like the the
person in your head you know the things
that you want to say and the way you
want to react but you like have to
polish yourself down yeah yeah be that
person there's a weird sense of being a
slice of life kind of film to it I don't
know I feel like are we talking deeper
about the movie that's really just an
offensive hangout movie yeah because
there are Parts
because it's it's simple but there's
also something admirable about like f
Gary Gray's Direction with this was at
times so like because yeah this is like
he's eventually gone on to do like
massive freaking films but but here you
know it feels an incredibly low budget
uh but there were times where I thought
he really leaned into like certain genre
tropes that I thought were impressive
and he he managed to ring out a a with a
movie that was like okay so this is just
like a like 30 minutes since it was like
oh this is just a movie about like
random instances of things that are
happening on a Friday night kind of all
like tying at the end yeah exactly
that's what was impressive to me it all
like coalesced together by that and then
it and it got a little real worldy at
times and and it had a and had a sense
of tension and I did find as I was like
what exactly is happening in this movie
it took me a while to adjust to it and
then even by the end with Ice Cube as
Craig when he does have that fight and
he like arcs into being a man like
finally being able because he's like
he's 22. he's just a child at home and
then you're by the end of it he's like
okay this is setting him I don't know
what the sequels do but at the end of
this it's like okay set an amount of
path to really be a man finally and and
so I was like oh there's actually even
like a good character article for this
guy that I didn't even really see coming
so yeah I was surprising it wasn't like
I was cracking up for most of it
um no but it was entertaining through
and through not a dull moment for me
yeah that's what I mean like it because
you're just kind of wondering why
everything is happening and I'm like why
are why all these characters are
introducing it um you're kind of like oh
why did they put that in but I think
that in terms of characters this movie
was really rich in that in that sense
because
um I feel like now movies
like you know what characters put there
for like a specific reason and I feel
like I kind of missed when characters
just kind of existed for no other real
reason other than I don't know just just
to be it's just more realistic to me to
just have people come in and out that
really have nothing to do without me
because I'm just like yeah that's real
life like honestly well it's like the
hangout Vibe of the neighborhood just
they're chilling on their porch and it
just [ __ ] just keeps happening in the
neighborhood and I'm like it's it is it
is it does bring that Community to life
and it does like what you were talking
about with feeling like they wrote from
experiences like you you get the vibe
that okay this character is based off
someone they knew then this character is
based off someone they knew then
and also the dad uh John Witherspoon
that's so funny he's so funny and then
he had such a great tender scene and I
was like Wow how'd they do this how'd
they make it oh he's a great actor
because he went from being kind of like
ridiculous and you know like that kind
of Trope dad and then he actually had a
real moment with him where I was like
damn like this got deep but in a but you
believed it it wasn't like
uh like the tone definitely went back to
being serious like I feel like the tone
in this movie you could tell when they
shot certain scenes like they nailed it
I feel like but yeah they're
I felt like with the dad like what you
said it was believable because it didn't
feel like this isn't the same character
all of a sudden you know because he's so
wacky and so sketch comedy like
um when he is just like vulgar and
off-putting and I feel like you know
what's funny I was thinking in the
beginning the whole dynamic with the
whole family like in the very beginning
I was laughing to myself because I'm
like this is like real life and how like
family bickers but you'll never see that
no offense like in a in a white movie
it's always like honey I made you this
really amazing breakfast and they're
like sorry Mom I'm gonna be late for
school I'm like that doesn't I've never
had that happen in my life and it's like
you're always just like talking [ __ ] to
each other but like you love each other
um and I feel like when white people
write family it's just like not like
that at all but I feel like that's just
like more real the way they did it is
like way more realistic for like
siblings to like you know put each other
down and [ __ ] but then they at the end
of the day like they're still gonna you
know be there for them and stuff so I
I'm like that it just was like
refreshing to see that
um and when when he was like oh he
didn't understand why his mom was like
married to his dad because he thinks his
dad is like dumb disgusting but then you
have that really dark deep moment
between them and you're kind of like
okay that's like he's still a husband
he's still like a good dude and he's
been through [ __ ] and especially with
that line when he's like oh I'm gonna
beat you up like your dad used to get
beaten up like you kind of understand
why yeah his dad is the way he is and
yeah it's true I did say that at the
beginning and then the movie answered it
for me actually exactly actually brought
it and did you said it not him okay I
was like yeah yeah uh no I've ever said
at the beginning like why would you
marry him like and yeah and then I I
asked myself that every time I see a lot
of people
and uh the villain the Debo you just saw
a Fifth Element didn't you with John
yeah yeah yeah we watched it together it
wasn't Debo the president in Fifth
Element
that's where I saw him from because I
was like looking at him I was like I
just saw him in something and I couldn't
figure it out because he looks out I
feel like he looked very different was
that I think so you need to look it up
Tom Lister uh I think it's I mean here
is credited as uh I mean
I don't know if it goes by a Tiny Lister
Tommy Lister Jr that's who it is I mean
he's been acting for like ages you're
right he wasn't well yeah he's got like
such a difference like 100 credits to
his names guys he's a great actor 220
credits to his name my God good for him
man wow I thought when they when they
had that moment sitting there and it was
like this beat and I thought they were
just gonna look at each other and like
they were gonna try to get him to beat
up the
the guy was asking for money but he's
also in uh The Dark Knight when uh with
the boats at the very end with choosing
the boats he takes the controller and
throws it out the the window do you
remember that scene at all
yes
no that was a really really really
heartfelt moment in that movie like a
moment of humanity imagine just having
that booking that you know what I mean
yeah in the dark night that's that's
King [ __ ] right there this dude for him
this dude has been acting forever oh
yeah and him and Chris Tucker are both
in Jackie and Tarantino's Jackie Brown
look at his IMDb right now this is kind
of crazy he's he was he was really
effective too because he did ride that
great line of like being funny but also
being like just scary like scary
terrifying I think the Jaws theme helped
too yeah that's true
um yeah I don't know that was a ride
that was fun yeah it was this is like a
movie you'd have on like if you're like
you know throughout the day if you're
just not really doing much and you have
this movie on and you're just like
hanging out with friends or something
like a little baked having a good little
baked I wasn't going to say it but it
was implied yes
uh yeah that was that was a fun movie
and uh I thought it had a little bit
more poignancy than I expected but
overall it was like an interesting just
I like a good Slice of Life I mean
usually a slice of life's are like you
know
yeah
yeah they could be depending on what it
is it could be boring you made a good
point though I would have loved for him
to uh have eaten that cereal with the
water and been like this is amazing
that's what I thought oh cereal when
you're baked is the best Fruity Pebbles
man that's my go-to fruity I was gonna
say pretty bubble
I just got a like um
a new face very expensive like facial
serum and it smells like Fruity Pebbles
and Fruit Loops okay that's interesting
I don't know if I want to smell
someone's face smelling like Fruity I
think it's it's to smell like Fruity
Pebbles I did have a candy rather smell
like that than Felicia that's true
no we're so mean no but I laughed
because like she got super close to him
she kept getting close and he kept like
moving away and it's always people that
smell or have bad breath that get like
so close to you like when I worked
retail
um I don't know why they it's like
almost like they just know you're you're
like not into it fascinating Sally
fascinating yeah there's
guys you can check out Sally's uh she
starts at Texas Chainsaw Massacre short
film
I was in a Texas Chainsaw Massacre like
on an official fan film and um
yeah I look disgusting so check it out I
feel like everyone on set was like the
DP was like now go lie you it's so gross
I was like thanks no no no it was good
horror movie it's it's the kind you look
like you know
it's repulsive but
that I will say I cut up my legs we did
a drone shot like running through the
cornfield and they didn't end up using
it they cut me out of it and oh
it's just it's okay
I mean I know why they did it we have
gone all over the place here Breaking
Down The Dark Knight
salvation
I'll let you watch something if the
fifth element with John Where Are You
Gonna you know have a pretty cool
conversation and I'm like let's talk
about Spaceballs and Fridays too two
very different Oddball quirky comedies
so but yeah guys follow Sally on our
YouTube channel and uh she's got some
fun stuff coming out and follow her on
social media as well
she does not post bikini photos
not anymore
I mean maybe
I won't scattered maybe soon major
trouble once for do you remember that I
remember that I don't know why I like
thought about it the other day sounds
like a joke and then oh man remember
that big fight I got it too oh that was
some neighborhood Friday [ __ ] yeah
that's a big argument oh man that was so
darling
oh man I feel like I made amends with
that person but I don't recall if I did
now this is like she was like five years
ago so I don't remember
um five or six I don't think that person
no offense is like relevant to our lives
anymore like I don't give a [ __ ] even if
you did Kathy I gotta I gotta resolve I
gotta take care of the dramas of my past
you know I I gotta tend to unresolved
arguments anyway she doesn't post those
photos anymore
talking about it thank you all for
single now so so maybe I will I don't
know that's not going to be more modest
don't don't lure with that or maybe
whatever helps you get more followers
are you being a dad right now are you
like don't post bikini photos I I mean
you can
don't you know uh depends so you're like
an older brother you're like please I
don't want to see that why why would you
what would be the purpose of doing it is
it to to get more followers to to find
to get an attractive guide there really
isn't I mean the guys in my DMs
and then it doesn't go anywhere you know
so
a bikini pick has never gotten me
anything really
no I get a [ __ ] ton of likes it
definitely boosts my the algorithm you
know like I know why girls do it because
it does get them like more likes and
followers but I'm like what is that if
it's not money I don't you know what I
mean
that's true if you can't monetize your
body what's the point you're not giving
me money like and I'm not gonna make an
only fan so sorry about it all right
guys thanks for being here catch you all
soon have a great Friday
foreign